mit kruste braune blätter super slim in
zoos mir ist aufgefallen dass sehr viele
schreiben hier sind exakt da beginnt
revolution im schwabenland hände täglich
deine spätzle ist keine chance wird sehr
peinlich für sie frau merkels wird sehr
peinlich und für dich auch wirklich
deine spätzle ist laut krone keine
chance lassen sie mich so zurückhaltend
wie möglich fragen was ist eigentlich
das problem der schwaben aber haben
jetzt um einen 1 im kritisches milieus
wir haben ein relativ stark esoterisches
milieu auch hier im südwesten dass auch
corona verschwörungstheorien glaubt und
es gibt glaube ich so eine gewisse
protestkultur gerade hier in baden
württemberg dass man vielleicht auch
nicht so das hat was man so libertäre
positionen nennen könnte wo man sich vom
staat möglichst wenig reinreden lassen
möchte
winterthur ja ich bin unterwegs und
streite für
die rückgabe meine grundrechte ich bin
bewegt weil ich sehe dass das dicke
verdreht werden wissenschaftlich aus
meiner zunft sogar das ist die zunft
medizin
ich bin arzt was für eine art stunden
guter hoffe ich und reicht es wenn man
einen mindestabstand zur wissenschaft
wie meine instituts der dass man dann
gesichert ist welche wissen schon was
meinen sie ich verstehe ihre frage nicht
also wenn sie mich nur provozieren
wollen sie haben sie den falschen
gesprächspartner
sie sind auch nicht vom zdf es bewarben
sie nur sie sind von der linken warum
haben viele dieser
verschwörungstheoretiker so ein
wahnsinniges mitteilungsbedürfnis
verschwörungstheoretiker die man so
trifft auf diesen demonstrationen die
sind ja genuin überzeugt davon dass sie
erkannt haben was wirklich vor sich geht
es tut mir sehr leid dass du getötet
wurdest weil an konzerts in die hölle wo
kommen sie hin
ich komme in den himmel und was ist im
himmel so nah himmels spaß friede freude
eierkuchen und bei dir ist halt arsch
lecken und wollen das natürlich
verbreiten und wollen andere leute auch
überzeugen davon die welt so zu sehen
wie sie sie sehen und deshalb ist es so
dass man entweder gar nicht mit denen
ins gespräch kommt die frage warum
oder wenn es funktioniert wenn man sich
nie mehr wieder los
wo noch konzept schimon peres hat gesagt
das bad von zitrus verschieben muss wie
baue ich eine richtig gute
verschwörungstheorie in eine richtig
gute verschwörungstheorie da brauchen
sie erst mal eine dunkle gruppe der sie
das alles in die schuhe schieben dürfen
z
zdf zum beispiel aber das reicht dann
nicht das zdf muss mit irgendwem anders
gemeinsame sache machen sagen wir mit
den illuminaten und mit schalke 04
ja also eine perfekte
verschwörungstheorie wäre das zdf will
mit hilfe der illuminaten schalke 04 zum
deutschen meister machen
das halte ich für fast so abstrus
schalke 04 zum deutschen meister zu
machen dass das nicht mehr die
verschwörungstheorien glauben aber wir
wissen aus erfahrung abstruser desto
mehr wer das nicht glaubt wer steckt
hinter dem betrug das sind die so
genannten 400 familien das sind die
menschen denen die internationalen
konzerne gehören die gerade praktisch am
end im endzustand des monopolist muss
angelangt sind und uns in ein neues
mittelalter befördern wollen die uns
weltweit entrechten und verelenden
wollen die stecken dahinter also es
abstand halten und maske tragen kommt
ist absoluter quatsch
warum halten sie dann soviel abstand zum
gesunden menschenverstand
er ist einfach nur eine frechheit ich
wurde am 12 ich bin hier informiert und
ich wehre mich dagegen was hier gesagt
wurde gilt nicht für alle schreiben
ich habe mal einen x-beliebigen schwaben
auf der straße angesprochen vielleicht
stellen sie sich erst mal vor eine
stunde oettinger querdenker sollten auch
argumente prüfen erklärt denken ist eine
verpflichtung dass man die besseren
argumente sucht und nicht schwachsinn
verkauft in jeder pflanze in jedem tier
in jeder begegnung in jeder
zwischenmenschlichen begegnung ist die
liebe zu können auch zwischen uns exakt
genau und ob die das zulässt oder nicht
das liegt an dir ja ich denke dass man
das ende hause von der korona demo für
mich stellt und damit zurück in meine
starken solo war noch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]